welcome to best life 30 your 30-day
journey to creating the best life
possible for yourself you can just watch
this video or if you want to sign up for
the entire series for free and get the
companion bonus worksheets that go with
this video check the link in the
description below alright so today is
day 16 and we're gonna learn how to
create an amazing morning routine every
morning in seal training my instructors
who at the time we're all Vietnam
veterans would show up in my barracks
room and the first thing they do is
inspect my bed if you did it right the
corners would be square the covers would
be pulled tight the pillows centered
just under the headboard and the extra
blanket folded neatly at the foot of the
rack it was a simple task mundane at
best but every morning we were required
to make our bed to perfection it seemed
a little ridiculous at the time
particularly in light of the fact that
we were aspiring to be real warriors
tough battle-hardened seals but the
wisdom of this simple act has been
proven to me many times over if you make
your bed every morning you will have
accomplished the first task of the day
it will give you a small sense of pride
and it will encourage you to do another
task and another and another and by the
end of the day that one task completed
will have turned into many tasks
completed making your bed will also
reinforce the fact that the little
things in life matter if you can't do
the little things right you'll never be
able to do the big things right and if
by chance you have a miserable day you
will come home to a bed that is made
that you made and a made bed gives you
encouragement that tomorrow will be
better so if you want to change the
world start off by making your bed
there's a reason why the visionary
founder of Starbucks Howard Schultz
Isis before the something there's a
reason why Michelle Obama rice very
early there's a reason white Tim Cook
who's leaving Apple gets up before the
dawn first of all the hours in between
four and six are the time of least
distraction in this age of dramatic
interruption number two the hours before
the Sun rises
is the period where your brain is most
available to your primary creativity so
while you're sleeping your brain
actually washes itself but also it lets
them go the residue of the previous day
while you are resting and while you are
recovering when you wake up your
thinking is fresh your creativity is
most pristine you are most available to
access your gifts and your talents so
those are some of the reasons why I
encourage you to get a Braille you might
say Robin while I'm not an early riser I
can't put mine over mattress I can't win
the battle up the bed grandma never got
up early
and get up early I guess about the kind
of person who could rise before the Sun
and what I would suggest to you is
simply this
what science confirms in particular the
data of University College London you do
any new habit and practice it for 66
days and you will arrive at the place of
automaticity in other words it'll be
easier to run the new habit than not 266
days of rising at 5:00 a.m. will get you
to a place where it's easier to get up
at 5:00 a.m. then not to get up at 5:00
a.m. you'll reach a place of
automaticity and by book the five am
club i say all change is hard at first
and it's messy in the middle and it's
gorgeous
at the end I'll repeat that again
because it's so important all change is
hard at first
messy in the middle and it's gorgeous at
the end in the book there's a chapter on
the habit installation process that
actually explains the three phases every
habit goes through before you wire it
into the place where it's automatic
number one destruction number two
integration and number three
implementation really important to
remember them so you
get up early you can install habits as a
matter of fact neuroplasticity which is
the phenomenon that speaks to the fact
the brain is like a muscle the more you
flex it and push it the more it's gonna
grow you have that gift it's not just
for Federer and Serena Williams and
Oprah Winfrey and Shakespeare and Joe
Michele Basquiat and Steve Jobs and Elon
Musk you have a brain that has the
capability to grow and adapt what is the
20-20-20 formula that lies at the core
of the 5 a.m. club method well the first
20 minutes move sweat you'll release
BDNF brain-derived neurotrophic factor
which will increase the neural
connections of your brain as well as
repair brain cells damaged by stress and
also promote neurogenesis which is the
formation of new brain cells I know this
is a lot of information but I want to
give you great content in this video
exercising for 20 minutes first thing
the morning from 5 to 5:20 the first
part of the 20-20-20 formula releases
dopamine which is the inspirational
neurotransmitter how valuable is that
for your creativity productivity for the
rest of the day cortisol the fear
hormone is highest first thing in the
morning exercising will reduce it
serotonin is released so you'll feel
happy
now it's 5:20 you're full of energy
you've optimized your cognition your
focus is increasing
it's only 5:20 the rest of the world is
asleep just imagine that advantage you
already have second pocket for the
20-20-20 formula is all about reflection
we live in a world where people don't
reflect anymore a lot of people are busy
being busy what's the point of being
busy around the wrong things so for 20
minutes from 520 to 540 you reflect you
pray or write in a journal meditate you
can visualize you can script out a
blueprint for a great day ahead which
habit researchers call a pre commitment
strategy which actually increases your
willpower and your ability to get your
most important priorities done okay now
it's 5:40 from 5:40 to 6 o'clock this is
the final 20 minute pocket the 20-20-20
formula the first pocket was about moved
the second is reflective the third is
grow of coached billionaires and CEOs
NBA superstars and members of royalty
for over 20 years here's what I realized
when I work with the best of the best
they love to learn they
to grow they don't see investing in
yourself or investing in your skills or
investing in your growth a cost they
think about the value received I call it
the 2 X 3 X mindset to double your
income and your impact triple your
investment in two core areas your
personal mastery and your professional
capability so for 20 minutes what do you
do you listen to a podcast to review
your journal notes you read a book you
watch a valuable video you just do
something you read an autobiography you
do something to grow your capacities and
materialize more of the potential you
have been born into and now at 6 o'clock
you've optimized your mindset you've
purified your heart set you've
calibrated your health set you escalated
your soul set you feel fundamentally
different in the 5 M Club there's
another model called the 4 habits of
history makers and one of the elements
is day stacking the whole idea is simply
this get your morning's right your days
are going to be fundamentally more
energetic creative productive and
high-impact and a great week is nothing
more than a series of great days and a
great month is the same thing and a
great quarter is just a group a series
of well lived weeks and it just
continues and it creates this upward
spiral of success just by getting from 5
a.m. to 6 a.m.
your victory hour to world-class every
morning
consistency really is the mother of
mastery and on your morning you're
really going to elevate your life you
must come up with a morning routine that
you do every single morning or at least
more mornings than not that puts you in
control of yourself and in control of
your day this is what I do and I cannot
explain the power that I get from
starting my day off and being bigger
than my excuses and being in control
first and foremost wake up on time when
that alarm goes off get your butt out of
bed 5 4 3 2 1 go why is that important
for persistence the reason why is
because the first decision that you're
making of the day is to actually get up
and get moving
that means you are persistently bigger
than your excuses you are persistently
bigger than feeling lazy and you are
persistently beating the feelings that
typically stop you the second thing that
I want you to do before you look at your
email before you answer your phone
before you start surfing Vox and vice
and BuzzFeed and you know team stream
and checking out the sales on Zappos and
looking at your Facebook newsfeed before
you pick up the damn phone please please
please figure out your two priorities
for the day these are the things that
matter to you whether it's saving money
and and making sure you're focused on
that or showing up at work and being a
contributor or whether it's changing how
you treat your spouse or your kids or
the person that you're with or heck
getting to the gym because you said you
would whatever it is that your two
priorities are put them in your head
before you pick up the phone why the
reason why is because of persistence the
reason why is because I want you to have
a good day do you know what makes for a
bad day what makes for a bad day is
snoozing
starting your day off late starting your
day off tired starting your day off by
mainlining everybody else's newsfeed on
social media and looking at everybody
else's life and and saying to yourself
oh my god they're on vacation or gosh
they look so great or your friends are
so fancy or my gosh they've got so money
you start off your day looking at that
you're never gonna have a good day you
got to start off your day by getting up
on time figuring out your priorities and
then getting to work on them do not pick
up your phone until you have done those
two things I think the single biggest
reason why people have bad days is
because they start them off by looking
around at everybody else and seeing what
they're doing instead of having the
focus and the discipline to actually
start your day off with you in control
and with your priorities front and
center so you want a bonus rad exercise
every day
that's right get up on time figure out
your pre-trip priorities and exercise
you do those three things you'll be
kicking ass every single day
my very first thing I do when I wake up
in the morning is I want to get my head
right I do this thing called priming now
some people get up in the morning and
they meditate and I think meditation is
wonderful but I haven't met many people
that can not think thoughts this is a
different outcome this is about priming
yourself it's about putting yourself in
the state where your mind and body will
respond accordingly we all do three
steps it's really simple over 10 minutes
so why don't you sit down and I'll guide
you through it so just get really
comfortable I want to be sitting up is
that back enough for you to be able to
relax yeah good okay cool and then the
first thing you gonna do is your hands
are gonna come up as you take the breath
in and then you're gonna explode out the
nose down explosive that's it good
that's it keep going two more good now
relax keep your eyes closed
hope you four hands open if you would on
your lap face up like that just feel
whatever you feel just take it in you
don't have to respond to me anymore you
just enjoy it and take it in and now
just let your body relax deeply and I'd
like you to begin to think of a moment
in your life you could feel really
grateful for if you wanted to it could
be something little rich or it could be
something big it doesn't matter it could
be from your childhood or this week it
doesn't matter do your best to remember
it and then step into it as if you were
there kind of like stepping in your body
and seeing what you saw then through
your own eyes hearing what you heard
then feeling what you felt then
savor it
maximize that sense of appreciation or
enjoyment or gratitude
enjoy it feel it fill up with it and now
we're going to ship to the last piece
really simple all you're gonna do is
focus on three things one at a time that
you want to accomplish three things you
want to achieve live it and feel it and
experience it
I was not
yeah what you feel yeah there's two
worlds the master the external in the
internal world they both have to be
bastard but if you master the external
world you know Allah you know Robin
Williams will master the internal world
there's a big price this is the one to
master first and so I start my day by
making that so I have this base to do it
I'm gonna live from gratitude today I'm
gonna live from blessing you know I'm
gonna be a blessing people's life today
I'm gonna get stronger today and I'm
gonna achieve what I'm you're committed
to do and the whole thing you know we
did that one in the less than 10 minutes
to give you an idea no one can live
without a routine you just forget that
if you guys don't have a routine I would
recommend like you get one going because
you cannot be mentally healthy without a
routine you need to pick a time to get
up whatever time you want but pick one
and stick to it because otherwise you
dis regulate your circadian rhythms and
they regulate your mood and eat
something in the morning I had lots of
clients who've had anxiety disorders I
had one client who was literally
starving very smart girl sheet there's
very little that she liked she kind of
tried to subsist on like half a cup of
rice a day she came to me and said I
have no energy I come home all I want to
do is watch the same movie over and over
what like is that weird and I thought
well it depends on how hard you work you
know it's a little weird but whatever
it's familiar you're looking for comfort
so I did an analysis of her diet it's
like three quarters of a cup of rice
it's like you're starving eat something
you know you'll feel better
so she modified her diet and her all her
anxiety went away and she had some
energy it's like yeah you got to eat so
a schedule that's a good thing man your
brain will thank you for it it will
stabilize your nervous system which is a
bit of a plan that's a good thing the
first 60 minutes or so are very clearly
defined and that's the recipe I use to
set up the rest of the
step number one I wake up and I meditate
for 20 minutes typically 22 minutes it's
20 minutes of seated transcendental
meditation it could be pasta it could be
headspace and then 2 minute
decompression period where I sit there
and let my mind do whatever it wants to
do I get up brew tea very frequently
Gulam tea or some combination of say
turmeric ginger and puer that's another
favorite and then I sit down to journal
and there are two different types of
journaling that I do depending on the
day for different purposes one would be
morning pages where I'm effectively
vomiting my brain onto the page to trap
my monkey mind in print so that it
doesn't bother me for the rest of the
day the other type of journaling I do is
best encapsulated in a journal called
the five minute journal they're
different ways to do this but I'm
writing down three or four bullets of
items people relationships anything that
I'm grateful for which is a very very
very nice way to set the rest of the day
so that you're viewing life through a
lens of positivity then there are a few
questions related or prompts I should
say related to focal points for the day
ideally immediately after that I'm
having a small amount to eat and then I
would go into exercise of some type that
exercise could be riding on a on a
peloton bike and doing a 20-minute hit
workout high-intensity interval training
or it could be a crow yoga or could be
weight training or working on a concept
to rower and that would be generally no
more than 60 to 90 minutes in length
sometimes it's as short as 20 minutes
and then shower off to the day grant
rant of the day the one you need to live
with wake up to every day is that right
there okay beat the Sun up folks
you got to beat the Sun up if you can't
beat up the roll up of the Sun up you're
gonna get beat up in life okay I've been
doing this for a long time now say beat
that thing up that monster out there
that warms this planet that nourishes
and gives us light but you can't live a
10x life if you're not beating the Sun
up so many of you complain about how
much time you have you don't have time
man because you don't beat the Sun up
get started early
and when you get started early that
means you need to shut it down early
okay shut it down or at least so you get
sleep I was I was I was asleep last
night at nine o'clock so I could beat
the scent up the market this morning and
see the world wake up with me I
prioritize trying to win the battle in
the morning so I always win the battle
of mourning so I get more anytime every
morning I go for a run that's the first
thing I do every morning haven't taken a
day off of running since December 2016
I've every day up in the morning so I
also stretch out every day for about two
or three hours every day I've missed two
days and about five and a half six years
so that's just my routine in about four
days a week I'm in the gym hitting the
weights because you know you can't just
be a runner so this is every single day
the the monotony of my life but this is
what builds discipline you know and not
everybody I'm not to tell everybody to
do this but this is my lifestyle this is
how I build self-discipline walk me
through a day in the life what's it look
like right now well I mean it's got to
be crazy right now I leave here and I
fly out to Oregon and I'll be in Oregon
with Cameron Haines
we'll be getting at you for a few days a
lot more podcast lot more interviews but
every day every morning I get up I still
get my run in every morning how do you
structure of the training the training
is basically structured off of my
schedule so look at my schedule yeah
that's okay Jennifer would we have today
we have this at 7 o'clock in the morning
Roger that that means I got to be up by
4 o'clock in the morning to run that's
how it works
that's all my works so she lays out the
schedule of events to out you just you
just set it two hours earlier she says
it could take an hour to get to rich
rolls let's say we were at 7 o'clock
today in the morning it takes an hour to
get to rich rolls with no traffic ok
that's that's blocking an hour 15 for
rich roll okay we got that
good morning time I'm gonna run 7 miles
this morning I need 52:34 that Roger
that put in shower shave add that in so
the schedule dictates but I have all
oh [ __ ] back right so that means getting
up at 1:30 trust me
Roger that I've done that several times
yeah several how much sleep do you
usually get I I like getting seven to
eight hours of sleep
nowadays I can do that but there's times
where the schedule says hey man you're
getting three hours and if that's the
case right Merry Christmas
when I wake up in the morning the first
thing I do is I do a gratitude exercise
where I ask myself use the in bed what
am I most grateful for today and usually
you know I'm grateful for my health I'm
grateful for my wife I'm grateful for my
children grateful to be alive I'm
grateful you know for my family I'm
grateful to to have experiences and used
to do that
eyes closed yeah I do that eyes closed
and while I while I think about that I
feel it and so the feeling starts every
day with a great feeling
mmm I start every day with a great
feeling you have do you visualize some
things you've liked your children or do
you talk to yourself how do you do that
yeah I have an internal dialogue I see
images of the things that I'm thinking
about and that just takes me two minutes
just two minutes when I wake up and then
I go to exercise to take care of my body
how long usually one hour to an hour and
15 minutes every day and so I do a
variety of different things I hike I
bike I work on aerobics that work on
strength I work with weights I do
whatever it is I just do it to give my
body the physical exercise then as soon
as I finish my exercise in my chair when
hour and an hour now or 15 minutes at
the most so then in my gym I have two
things I have a vision board which is my
dream board for my class I know you all
know about that yes
so I have my vision board for my my
physique in my body in my health but
then I also have in in my gym something
called an achieved board okay so how do
I achieve some of the things that I
achieve biased on the future no achieved
in the past yes so fast you get fast in
the future yeah so I have in my in my
gym in
home gym I have a like a place where I
sit and before I start my meditation I
look at my vision board from the past
okay so I get connected to the different
things that I've been able to achieve
and I remember every day when I set my
mind and my focus to achieving goals I
can achieve all of my goals what I also
do is I reinforce most people focus on
what's not working just isn't going well
this didn't work I want to remind myself
every day yeah look how many things I
was able to accomplish by being clear by
being passionate by using these rituals
so before I go into my meditation which
is with my eyes closed I look at my
achieved Board I get emotionally
associated with it to remind myself that
when I set my mind to achieve something
I can do it and then I look across
because I have a mirror in the gym and I
look across and I say I love you just
the way you are and I said I accept you
just the way you are with all of your
skills and passion and faults and
insecurities and doubts and fears I
accept you just the way you are why and
I smile and then I close my eyes and I
do about a fifteen minute meditation
well and in my meditations sometimes I
have no thoughts where I'm just one with
the universe and everything in turn
other times I'll just follow my thoughts
and I'll just pay attention be mindful
of were they going this morning
where they going today so I'll follow my
thoughts and I'll just follow them other
times I'll follow a thought and say
release that one and follow another
thoughts a release that one so I am
teaching my brain that I'm in control of
my brain first of all your morning
routine starts the night before so go to
bed early but I try to go to bed as
close to 9:00 as humanly possible every
night save for the weekends
and in that I sleep without an alarm so
I wake up when I wake up the reason that
I do that is because I want to get as
much sleep as I need so I'm all about
cognitive optimization so I'm not
somebody who sets the alarm to make sure
that I'm up at 4:00 in the morning but
when I wake up at 4:00 in the morning
I'm a very happy camper I usually get it
used to be between five and six I'm now
getting between seven and eight I have
no idea why I changed completely
randomly and as far as I can tell
without reason but I wake up when I wake
up I give myself ten minutes to get out
of bed and I do that because I'm lazy
and my inclination is to lay in bed so I
need a bright line this as I get out of
bed immediately without wasting time so
I'm out of bad and out of bed in ten
minutes or less I put my gym clothes
next to my bed so that the easiest
answer is to put my gym clothes on in
fact I'd have to make a conscious choice
not to which dust would trigger in me a
lot of conflict emotionally because it
is my identity to immediately go to the
gym to work out again partly for
cognitive optimization and then also for
longevity for health and for aesthetics
but working out I think is incredibly
important and I actually think that for
anybody that wants to achieve something
extraordinary in their life that the
third thing that you need to focus on is
mindset the first two are diet and
exercise followed by mindset so I hit
the gym first and foremost immediately
after the gym I meditate and the reason
that I do that is because I want to
practice going from the sympathetic
nervous system which is fight-or-flight
which are triggering in the gym through
the heavy exertion your heart rate is up
your breathing is shallow and rapid and
the idea is to very quickly switch over
into the parasympathetic nervous system
where you're getting into rest and
digest where you're calming all of that
down you're slowing your breath your
diaphragm breathing in through the nose
out through the mouth and really calming
everything down and I think practicing
that transition is very important and so
that's why I do them back-to-back but
then on top of that just meditating for
any reason I think is really important
don't press snooze snooze doesn't help
but loses one of the things that just
sees a dream killer yeah it's like a
sister's ball notorious for that's it
that's right yeah it's like a complete
think it's gonna help you dream more but
it's not destroyed it's a psychological
trick if you pursues the thing that you
think pressing the snooze helps you with
like I just get that extra eight minutes
asleep that eight minutes asleep
building to be any more energy by the
way 18 seconds there's a there's an 18
second window in the morning when your
alarm goes off that sucks
it's about 18 seconds so 18 Negri alarm
goes off and you touch it yeah the next
18 seconds are like hard there that's
when you have to use maximum effort to
clear the gravitational pull of your
pillow
if you can get away from those 18
seconds
then you're okay you just get up get
away from the pillow it's pulling you in
some tractor beam I need to get away
from that and so that 18 seconds and
once you're up and you're moving a bit
now I've got a special bonus cup that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the best live 30 questions
of the day
it's not enough to just watch a video
you have to do something about it so
pull out your worksheets and answer
these questions and if you don't have
the worksheets yet get them for free by
checking the link in the description
below here we go question number 1 how
will you take control of your morning
tomorrow number 2 how will you prime
yourself for success and number 3 what
does an ideal structure for the rest of
your day tomorrow look like and if
you're doing the best live 30 challenge
with me put a hashtag best live 30 in
the comments below we want to celebrate
you nobody wakes up every day and says
this is gonna be the greatest day ever
not deadlock not Evan Carmichael not
Tony Robbins nobody you wake up and
you're tired and you have stuff in your
eyes and you have lines on your face
from the pillows the difference between
successful people is that they demand
excellence from themselves to the habits
and routines that they do daily the
problem is that thinking that these
people are different that if you're not
waking up with tons of motivation ready
to take on the day that something is
wrong with you
the only thing that's wrong with you is
you don't have the habits that set you
up for success every single day and
today I want to change that so I have a
5s morning routine that I go through
every single day that sets me up for
success that demands excellence I'm
gonna share with you guys today the
first s is sing the fastest way to
change your state is to put on music the
fastest way to go from feeling lower
energy tired bored into an energy of I
am ready to go is music put on the song
not that makes you feel the current way
that you're feeling this is where most
people mess up you put on music for how
you're currently feeling if you're
feeling really sad and low-energy you're
gonna put on really mellow
slow music what does that do it keeps
you in the same state that you're in it
keeps you exactly where you are what you
want to do is put on the music for how
you want to feel and so I have a
playlist
main channel called the bleep playlist
which is the songs I listen to these are
the songs that I listen to every day
they may work for you they may not work
for you there's no perfect song for
everybody there's the perfect song for
you and so build a playlist are the
songs that make you come alive here's
the criteria if this song came on it
would force you to start moving if the
song came on you find yourself doing
this it's a song came on you would get
out of your chair and want to move
around does it mean you gonna dance like
crazy doesn't mean you're gonna start
building up the lyrics that maybe you
awesome but if you're a little more
introverted or don't like the dance
something that would make you move
something that would get you at least in
your chair doing this that's what I want
make a playlist and put that on as the
first thing that you do every single
morning it'll make a huge difference to
setting the tone changing your state and
giving you energy and momentum to start
the day that's number two is Sun I like
getting outside I think there's
something about getting outside of your
home of your condo your apartment
getting outside getting some fresh air
just being out in nature makes a big
difference getting some getting some
vitamins on your face from the Sun
outside but also signifying that your
your leaving your bedroom your leaving
the condo the apartment the home you're
leaving what happened last night and
you're ready to go off and start the day
this is especially important if you're
working from home because it's easy to
have your you know office right next to
your bedroom or maybe your office is
your bedroom and carry that bedroom
energy that tired I just woke up I want
to stay in bed I want to sleep energy
into your work and you won't do great
things if that's the energy you're
carrying to your work so having some
kind of ritual that splits up sleeping
energy - I'm ready to go energy makes a
big difference and I find the easiest
way to do it is to get outside and get
some Sun bonus points if you're in a
condo or apartment to take the stairs
instead of the elevator that's number
three is soar and this is the most
important thing for me if you only take
one of the five I think this is the most
important one to take what is the thing
that makes you sore every day what's the
thing that makes you feel alive bold
confident what is that and put it into
your morning routine at some point in
your life you felt bold you felt
unstoppable you felt confident it's
happened to everybody the problem is you
don't feel that way consistently
day you go through these bursts these
moments of man I could do such amazing
things but then the next day you wake up
on you're a different person you're back
to the I don't know if I can do it I
don't know who am I to go do this crazy
thing that's the problem
so whatever the thing is that makes you
feel like you can come alive that gives
you that boldness and confidence plan it
with intention every single day into
your morning routine for me what I do is
I record a message on my phone to
Instagram to my stories to I put it to
LinkedIn and Twitter right now I'm
putting it everywhere but I need to make
a message so I think of somebody that I
helped yesterday I think of somebody who
commented on the video who I met in
person who I coached on my Instagram
live somebody that I helped yesterday
and then I make a message channeling
that person I won't say the person's
name but I have them in my head I need
to remind myself that the work that I do
is important it's easy to get lost in
numbers it's hard to imagine that two to
three hundred thousand people watching
my videos yesterday that's crazy it's a
wild number right while it's hard to
well like what does that even mean I
don't know I'm just sitting here talking
to a camera in my office and two to
three hundred thousand people are
watching my videos it's crazy I need to
think down to the actual person I need
to think about an individual that this
matters to somebody that the work I do
really mean something to them and then I
need to record a message and share that
helps me soar and I do it every day what
is the thing for you what makes you sore
maybe it's watching the 254 series that
I put up every day
maybe it's watching the in spresso
videos like this that I've put up every
day and some people every day this is
part of the morning routine this watch
dance presser video and I'm humbled to
be a part of your morning routine for
other people might be meditating there
might be watching the video or might be
reading the book and listen to a podcast
I don't care what the thing is but you
have felt bold unstoppable and confident
at some point in your life what led you
to feeling that way and then demanded of
yourself every day by putting it into
your morning routine
the third ass is sore it's the most
important one the fourth that's for me
is sweat this is just about being
healthy having a healthy lifestyle I
want to do something that makes me sweat
so whether it's a hit workout a cardio
workout a weights workout I put that
into my daily routine because I want to
bust a sweat and I wanna
stay healthy into my 40s which is coming
up and then into my 50s and Beyond and
then the last s for me is scare I want
to do something every day that scares me
what I'm doing right now is they take a
cold shower so after sweating I need to
have a shower they want to show up the
work I'll smelly and so hop in the
shower but right away start turning the
colder and colder and colder and colder
and colder and then right at the very
end I go all the way cold and I freeze
and even just thinking about right now
it sucks which is the best right you
want to do the thing that scares you
every day you're teaching yourself that
I do scary things so whatever is scary
for you whether it's taking a cold
shower whether it's making a phone call
whether it's sending an email making a
video and posting it doing scary things
teaching yourself getting that out of
the way Repton beginning I find really
helps me if you want to join the best
life 30 challenge click the link right
here below me or if you want more videos
to boost your morning routine check out
the playlist right there next to me
continue to believe and I'll see you
there